[Music]
hey TV lovers I'm Liana Galera and
welcome to et live and today I am both
thrilled and devastated to have my
friend Chandler Riggs joining me today
from the walking dead hi Chandler hey
how are you great great thank you so
much for stopping by today of course
we're gonna be chatting all about Carl's
big episode because the Walking Dead
returns this Sunday February 26th on The
Walking Dead 25th I'm getting too
excited getting too excited if for some
reason you fans tuning in right now have
not seen the mid-season finale I'm just
gonna let you know this whole thing is a
spoiler for you Chandler and I will not
just be talking about his favorite
putting flavors although I'm assuming
it's chocolate definitely send us your
questions right now because we're gonna
be getting into the nitty gritty but
you've been warned a spoiler alert Carl
got it
Chandler when you initially found out
that Carl was bit by a walker what was
your reaction I mean it was kind of the
same reaction I think that everyone had
really just kind of really surprised and
it was unexpected but you know when when
Scott kind of explained it all to me and
it really you know made sense for the
story and for you know for everyone's
characters it kind of made sense for it
to kind of drive the story forward yeah
and kind of take it where the show is
supposed to be going yeah I understand
that the Walking Dead showrunner Scott M
Gimple said that he wanted to talk to
you along with your parents when he
wanted to break the news of Carl's death
what was that conversation like it was
well when they were when they brought us
in it was um yeah I was definitely like
like an interesting thing because
usually he doesn't like bring me in with
my parents
yeah usually it's just like well cuz I
had actually I talked with him a couple
months before just like kind of like the
lay out the season and everything and he
didn't mention that you didn't have any
clue what I think he did I think he knew
what he wanted to do but just wasn't
sure yet but I think yeah I think by
then he kind of kind of made up his mind
but ultimately again for like you know
for the story and for effort everyone
else's story it really just kind of made
sense for it to happen and yeah
especially for my career too like it's
it's it really suck to be all off the
show but
you know I had such a great time like it
was really really awesome you have an 8
years like it's it's definitely an
experience that I don't regret you grew
up on our screens yes essentially you
had your formative years on the walking
dead take me back to that first season
what do you remember most so hot what
yeah at that quarry it was just
ridiculous yeah yeah
no is this the same hat every time I'm
assuming you in multiple hats multiple
has ok yeah yeah this I actually I had
the same hat from the second season up
until like season four or five and I was
like this thing is way too small we
could we got it we got it upgrade and I
think actually by season seven or eight
I had like Andy's old hat from like
season luck which is pretty cool that's
really cool yeah ya know how does it
feel for you to know because this is
such a unique situation the writers
broke this up they were revealed that
Carla's bit which we know in The Walking
Dead world means you eventually do die
you turn into a walker but we've had
this break to really get to digest that
and now I get to talk to you about it
and we haven't even seen you die yet how
do you feel about how they've laid out
this journey for you I think it's great
yeah I think you know it's it's it
really shows a humanitarian side to Carl
and how he's gonna you know what left he
has to teach Rick he's gonna spend his
last few moments kind of teaching Rick
as much as he can well and obviously the
goodbyes between Carl and his father has
got to be one of the toughest things
I've seen the episode and it's one of
the most heartbreaking things that I've
ever seen what was it like for you to
say goodbye to Andrew Lincoln well I
mean any goodbyes on the show isn't
really like a forever goodbye because
you know I always see them at
conventions and another projects here
and there but luckily that was like the
first scene that we filmed of the
episode was was that last scene to kind
of just get it out of the way
and I mean that whole scene it was just
like well actually that that that last
scene oh wait I can't talk about
afterwards yeah so just as like a
preview alert be sure to check it to ET
online immediately after you watch the
episode because Chandler will be
spilling all of the juiciest
after-show
episode details so stay tuned for that
BS let's let's tease away yeah from that
but I imagine it was just a
heartbreaking time it definitely was
yeah for everyone really and but you
know it was it was and actually when I
when I rap they they gave me like a hat
from the first season that that indie
war and a like a science talk t-shirt
that I wore from season one like frame
and everything it was a really cool
little send-off that's really awesome
yeah oh my gosh well you have been a
part of the series since gosh before
2010 because you filmed the pilot I
think in 2009 no yeah I was actually the
summer of 2000 okay great
so it has been eight years of your life
look back with me over Carl's journey
what has been one of your most favorite
moments I think my like number one
favorite moment ever was and I think
it's Season four Episode four or five
when basically you know a bunch of
walkers are at the prison and they they
break down the fence and they're they're
kind of bursting into the prison and
Rick and Carl like mow down all of them
with with machine guns that was the
coolest thing ever because uh Georgia
labor laws restrict children like under
14 from touching any firearms on set
okay until they're 14 and so then we've
shot that on the night of my 14th
birthday and Andy like came over like 90
me with a machine gun and everyone I
counted down it was it was the coolest
thing ever I felt like I was in the
video game it was like it was it was so
much fun to shoot and so much fun house
special yeah that is so cool yeah real
machine oh definitely yeah that's why
yeah that's why I like you know it was a
big deal because we I was actually
shooting a machine gun that's amazing
yeah oh my gosh we're starting to get in
so many awesome fan questions so thank
you guys keep them coming right now
Riley says thank you so much for
everything that you've done for the show
genndy says what are you gonna miss most
about Carl um you know I think he kind
of brought a really light you know a
really light area to the show and you
know between him and Judith at least Oh
yep there she is oh she's a cutie pie
yeah yeah although those twins are not
the most fun to work with it's hard for
toddlers to hit their mark no no it
really is yeah yeah that whole sequence
actually with what the Polaroids
everything that was it was not easy to
make her look at the camera but Carl
really embodied hope for so many people
you know when his mom passed she said
you're gonna beat this world and it's
looking like as at this point that's not
gonna be the case for him for those fans
who really looked at Carl as the beacon
of light on this show what do you want
to say to them I mean really it's it's
it's just like I thank you to the fans
it's it's like it's um it's such a way
to get like sent off the show like it's
it's the way the way it you know it goes
down it's such like a empowering way and
I think especially in this last episode
it's it's really gonna drive that that
excitement to kind of see where the
story goes next a lot more mm-hmm
Lauren says who will you miss from The
Walking Dead cast I mean really everyone
like everyone has been like hated like
not directly answer the question but but
it's it's everyone on the cast it has
been so so nice and really really
helpful and supportive with everything
that I've done and it's just like it's
been so nice like it's been the coolest
experience hand down and working with
Andy and deny and Alana and and everyone
has just been like such an awesome
experience well a lot of the fans are
saying they are going to miss you so
dearly but Yale has a question on
everyone's mind does Carl or right as
Carl love pudding so much what kid
doesn't love pudding honestly yeah yeah
I don't blame him and I don't think he'd
had pudding in years no yeah no it was
just such a I'm just chilling on the
roof eating the pudding
chowing down just chowing down did you
ever sowed make you sick
actually I look like tiny little thing
okay it's only a like like a quarter but
that's still a lot of pudding like it
was a good like five pounds of pudding
tonight to eat
but know that see was it was it was
really fun to film yeah that actually
that whole episode was like like that
that moment in episode like four or five
and that season was was super fun but
like the whole episode to episode nine
was like it was so much fun just because
it was it was all focused on me and I
really got to like kind of push my
boundaries it was really really fun
awesome yeah
Carrie says hi Chandler my question is
what's next for you College I've also
heard that music might be an option is
that true yeah yeah I actually I started
producing music about a year and a half
ago under the alias Eclipse and I'm just
now starting to put out some music and
about an EP at the beginning of this
month and I've got a show that I'm
playing in San Marcos Texas on Friday
and another show that I'm playing next
week another three more shows in May so
it's really geared up and I love that
you did it initially under an alias what
was the decision behind that I really
wanted to kind of kind of keep keep it
separate from from walking dead as much
as I could because I want people to
listen to my music because they like it
you know what I mean and it's it's it's
really cool to kind of see that starting
to happen and people really enjoying my
music just because they like my music
yeah it's awesome that's so cool
congratulations on that
thank you yeah Oh Carolyn says I just
don't think the Walking Dead will be the
same without you you will be missed
Amanda a very cool question right here
says what was it like to face your own
death it was it was kind of kind of
weird because I cuz it was really
unexpected I think with you know
everyone didn't no one really expected
it but I don't know the the way again
like the way he goes out is is like a
really I don't know I don't know like
what I don't like spoiling too much but
it's it's you definitely want to don't
do not want to miss the episode yes and
then check back to ET online because
we'll have all these answers oh this is
a great question kandi wants to know
will you come back and secretly portray
a walker like some of the other stars oh
no that would be awesome
yeah that that'd be pretty cool I'd love
to do that what kind of a walker cuz you
know we
well walkers we've had fence walkers and
we don't know the well walker has like
been hands-down my favorite walker no
it's it's so just what the maggots like
crawling out of it and everywhere it's
it's so well done and it beat it be so
cool do something like that
do you have a favorite Walker kill think
yeah there's been so many and I always
think Michonne's kills are pretty cool
yes is right through it yeah uh speaking
of Michonne have you seen Black Panther
cuz did move it yeah yeah Knight has
crushed it oh my gosh not surprisingly
for Walking Dead fans we knew that she'd
be amazing but did you see her go
through any of that training oh yeah no
she was like in between like shooting
Black Panthers she'd be you know on the
set of Walking Dead we'd be like then to
be talking about how she's like jumping
through jumping off of buildings and
like doing all there's all this crazy
stuff and then yeah it's I can't wait to
see it I'm so excited so good yeah
after after you die this weekend you
should go see ya keep sending your
questions these are fantastic Rhonda
wants to know she says you were the
person that always has Judas so what
will happen now her babysitter and
brother we all miss you so much
well I think Carlos spent a lot of time
not really in Alexandria as well Malia
sneaking out of the walls and everything
so having his first kid yep yeah so I
think he has I think he's got I think
she's got like some babysitters yeah I
feel like there's gonna be no shortage
of people no you know look after Julia
that's okay see what happens to Karl
they're gonna be like we've got her yeah
[Laughter]
well so we've also heard the news that
lauren cohan her contract might be up at
the end of the season she's possibly
signed on to an ABC pilot have you heard
anything about that I haven't yeah I
mean since I'm kind of like I don't know
here to think about the show anymore
really in it yeah yeah but I mean it's
after like seven years I mean it's it's
it's you know why a long time to be able
to show and I mean do
it's always it's always super fun like
doing something different and then
that's why I like being off the show
I've already done like two other films
and it's like doing other things as been
like super super fun yeah I haven't
gotten doing why I've got to play like
they like this this like psychopath
character and I've played like this well
you kind of did that for a season but
it's it's it's super fun to be able like
go and do other stuff mm-hmm
grace wants to know what was the hardest
scene that you ever had to film that's
coming up and yeah
yeah yeah I can see that yeah so I was
telling Chandler I saw the episode this
morning and then had to redo my whole
face of makeup cuz I cryed it off so you
guys definitely are gonna need some
tissues by your side definitely um now
that you are off the show have the
walking dead executive producers told
you how it's all gonna end no really I
haven't heard anything from anyone as
much as I would like to know I have no
clue but I'm an avid fan of the comics
so yeah I don't I don't know how the
show like would end any time soon
with the comics being young coming up on
200 how did that make you feel cos Carl
still alive in the comics yeah well
anything that that he's done in the
comics since you're a fan that you're
like oh I hope one day I get to do that
that you got to did you miss out on it I
think I mean definitely like I love the
whole his whole relationship with negan
and the whole whispers arc I was it was
really excited for but I mean ultimately
I you know I can actually do other stuff
and do like wake a little things yeah
it's definitely like definitely not a
bad thing everything happens for a
reason
exactly how many more seasons do you
think we could get of The Walking Dead
and do you personally have a vision for
how you'd like it all to end I honestly
don't know I mean my kind of vision
involved Carl it's pretend so I don't
know I don't I have no clue how I
couldn't know um but maybe called her
like they did like a movie or something
it'd be kind of cool that would be cool
I don't know yeah eight seasons in a
movie I'd be pretty cool I'm into that
yeah I'm into that
would you ever envision that Carl could
come back in like a flashback or dream
sequence oh definitely yeah I think it's
definitely yeah
this season or just in general I think
just in general yeah I know I'm well at
you know at the end of season seven
Abraham came back for like that like
flashback with Thanksgiving yeah that
was really sweet yeah yeah I would like
to think that Karl is gonna be looking
down over Judith and his family
definitely definitely well we are
running close to out of time so my
question for you is do you have anything
that you would like to say specifically
to the Walking Dead fans because they've
been on this journey with you since the
very beginning yeah I I really just want
to say thank you like to know the fans
and for supporting me this whole time
and and you know you guys are the reason
that I have a job and like that hey you
know have a career and I'm able to
really do what I love and it's because
of you guys I thank you so much well
Chandler thank you so much for sitting
with me and talking to me all about this
episode
do you have one final T's for what the
fans should be prepared for what are
some things that they need with them
before they tune in if you have any pets
you're gonna need them clothe them new
tissues all that stuff yeah all the good
things hold it yeah maybe a blanket to
snuggle up with definitely yeah and then
I'm thinking like a face mask cuz you're
gonna be puffy at work the next day
everyone's gonna be talking about it so
they're gonna need to watch it live yeah
yes and guys be sure to check each
eonline immediately after you watch the
episode because Chandler's gonna be
spilling additional spoilers that you do
not want to miss as soon as we get off
line we're gonna be chatting all about
that so stay tuned The Walking Dead
returns this Sunday February 25th at 9
p.m. on AMC tuned in because Chandler it
might be our last time seeing you bye
guys
we're wishing luck see you guys
[Music]